[Musica]
costo pasto mischiano sempre museo
servizio ea napoli bagnoli cave la
radice quando mi hanno chiesto di
partecipare molto devo assolutamente
niente no sono veramente onorato di
essere qui con tutti voi e di vedermi
interessati al nostro bellissima e
complicato mar mediterraneo
come sentito dal mio accento su nadal
regimi la ma entrambi i miei genitori
sono napoletani in questa cosa per lungo
tempo mi ha fatto sentire di non
appartenere né regine né a napoli quando
ho conosciuto il termine natoli de di
erri de luca
avrei tantissimo voluto dirlo di me
stessa nena floridi sono coloro che sono
andati a napoli e poi l'hanno dovuto
abbandonare per qualche ragione senza
mai abbandonarla nel cuore ecco io non
abbandonerò mai il cuore sarà per sempre
caso e soprattutto il nuovo devo
imparato questo rapporto intrinseco fra
gwen che per la traccia fondamentale
della mia ricerca fotografica e potrei
dire anche della mia stessa vita
perché qui che veniva spedita tutte le
estati ho i miei genitori
per passare l'estate circondata da tutto
l'entourage
specialmente femminile della mia
famiglia e quindi fa mia madre le sue
sorelle reni cugina aprendo questo
rapporto di
costante
figura in sinergia in cui tutti loro
riuscivano a essere fra di loro
contemporaneamente madri sorelle
e figlia il flusso quasi viscerale mi
sembrava tutto mare e la terra per cui
vinceremo se io sarei mai riuscito a
diventare come loro pur con questo senso
io non appartenenza e alla sua questa
irrequietezza missione ha portato
viaggiare in altri prossimi in città
molto grandi metropoli grandi metropoli
lui poteva incontrare persone che come
me senti ma questo senso di non
appartenenza
in fondo se ci pensiamo nelle grandi
metropoli come alla fine la stessa a
napoli sono tantissime persone che
sentono questo senso di non appartenenza
ma è proprio lì che costruiscono la loro
definizione di casa e fra queste persone
c'è una componente molto importante
quella femminile che costituisce la
trasmigrazione femminile moderna
ecco queste donne si trovano lontane
dalla propria casa della propria
famiglia e della società della cultura
di origine e si trovano a realizzarsi
come individui e in questa città che
insomma
ci arrivano doveva essere state insomma
ed in qualche modo esperimento non si
tirerà il concetto di stanza tutta per
sé ovviamente in maniera figurata e
materna genti scrivevi argini ha voluto
nel suo saggio ovvero una donna quando
si trova sola con se stessa riesce
finalmente a conoscersi libera dagli
stereotipi lontana dalle aspettative
della famiglia e della società
in questo modo riesce a realizzarsi come
individuo liberato e questa cosa porta
ovviamente se la fanno tante donne
contemporaneamente
costruzione di un nuovo immaginario
colonnino di
riconoscersi e quindi immaginare
collettivo mi sono liberato dagli
stereotipi ora se pensiamo alla storia
come donna nel mediterraneo non possiamo
che ricordarsi è una storia di
immigrazione
millenarie e di set resilienza costante
in questo senso diciamo la
trasmigrazione femminile moderna e si
inserisce
assolutamente come un continuum lineare
nello stare le donne del mediterraneo
testimonianza diretta con tv voglio
lasciare di tutto questo col tipico
parlato che è a manta un paio di origine
srilankese è nato a napoli
aumenta porta le sue origine origini
della sua madre terra elegantemente nel
sospetto pur con accento napoletano
perfetto
studia la federico ii di napoli e mappa
rappresenta il presente e il futuro di
questa terra come tutte le altre sorelle
che quotidianamente lottano anche fuori
dalla propria stanza per essere
semplicemente se stessa
grazie grazie